Hey youtubers it’s charlie and quite possibly
the greatest episode of sherlock just aired.
Since a lot of you might not have seen it
yet I’ll try to keep out as many spoilers
as possible, but be careful.
I’m also taking questions in the comments
for this video for my sign of three q and
a video tomorrow.
so if you have a question about episode 2
and want me to include it in the video.
Be sure to write it in the comments below.
I’ll post my breakdown a couple days after
that.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
So just like my last review I’m going to
do my Top 5 favorite things from the episode
and then my overall review.
So let’s go, we gotta keep this stag party
on schedule.
Number 5 - The editing.
Normally I talk about parts of the story,
but there was this incredible way the story
was told in several different scenes even
when sherlock wasn’t in his mind palace.
I love how sherlock essentially shows you
the end result first and then rewinds to show
you how they got there.
Like learning how sherlock became watson’s
best man while he was in the middle of his
wedding speech.
They’ve done mechanical things like this
with the story for a long time, but something
about this episode and the bright colors of
the wedding juxtaposed with the drab colors
of baker street just made it feel like you
were jumping down the rabbit hole of sherlock’s
past.
And the whole time the joke is on sherlock.
The series makes fun of him a lot, but this
episode was sherlock walking right into a
face full of pie.
4 - Sherlock Stag Party - Watching the writers
explain to us what sherlock and watson would
do at a stag party was amazing.
It’s a fair question, what would those two
do?
The general decline of the evening into what
ended as the funniest cases they’ve ever
attempted was brilliant.
I’m totally inviting drunk sherlock to my
stag party.
And we’re going to solve the shit out of
some cases.
3 - Sherlock’s Wedding Speech.
It’s a wedding episode and of course sherlock
was always going to be the best man.
But first watching a side character get her
own montage was so much fun and two, the comedy
of sherlock’s actual speech was so much
funnier when it got tied up in the greater
murder mystery.
It was like having a conversation with someone
who was flipping channels on the television.
Constantly jumping around in time and space,
or time and headspace.
2 - The Mind Palace internet chat room.
So let’s try not to spoil this too much
for people who haven’t seen it yet, because
a very notable character appears inside the
mind palace.
But just from a production stand point, seeing
the camera jump back and forth between the
real world and this really big set that looked
like an orchestra pit was so clever.
It was almost like sherlock was conducting
a symphony in his mind while carrying on a
conversation with all the chat room women.
I was also really impressed at how they visualized
sherlock imagining each woman changing as
a result of answers they gave him.
Of all the scenes I would think that that
would have taken the longest to shoot.
1- Soul Man Sherlock.
So without going into the plot or the more
specific details, a lot of people’s complaints
about Sherlock in episode 1 being a dick are
answered in this episode.
Throughout sherlock demonstrates that he’s
much more complex than we thought.
We actually learn a couple new things about
his personality and they place him in this
much warmer context.
If mycroft is the barometer for coldness,
then sherlock just became so much more precious
to
the fandom.
Overall this was my favorite episode of the
series so far.
Just to give you an idea for how I feel this
series fits into context with series 1 and
2, before sign of three.
My favorite episode was empty hearse.
So far each new episode this year has been
my new favorite.
I don’t think his last vow will be able
to top the preciousness of this episode, just
because weddings are so ripe for comedy and
character relationships.
As i mentioned earlier, the way the story
was told was so much more fun jumping around
in time and space so much.
Mostly because the filming locations looked
so different.
And even though they could have just decided
to have fun with watson’s stag party or
sherlock at the wedding, each moment was really
true to the characters and the larger story
of the murder mystery.
The episode also gave me some practical help.
I just found out which game I’m going to
play at my next party.
Try and guess what I’m talking about in
the comments.
and Let me know what your favorite moment
was.
Remember, post your questions for my q and
a video tomorrow.
Right now click here for my breakdown of episode
1 empty hearse and click here for my review.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!